hello everybody my name is Nia and I'm
the black female engineer I provide
content for you and aspiring software
engineers and today we're going to talk
about how I build my apps in seven days
yeah you've heard that right I can go
from this to this in just one week
whenever I have a new app idea I can't
sit on it for long because then I just
demotivate myself and also tell myself
all the reasons why it's not a good idea
and I can't have that because I'm trying
to build something here and even if
you're not trying to create something
for the outside world to see building
apps is a great way to get more
experience build up your portfolio and
ultimately show other people jobs Etc
that you know what you're doing that
they should hire you so how can we do so
in a way that doesn't take up all of our
time number one the very first thing I
do when I have a new app idea and decide
you know what I have seven days to build
this out is decide what my
MVP is MVP stands for a minimally viable
product and it's basically what is the
least functionality this app needs to
have so that it is technically a full
app fully working and the concept is
there for example I recently built out a
dating app where people would get to
rate their dates I wanted a way to know
that the people I'm going on dates with
were people who were going to be
insanely late going to be respectful all
the works and so what was my MVP well
it's a dating app so there needed to be
some type of matching mechanism number
two there needed to be some type of
messaging mechanism because how are we
going to get from swiping to a date so I
needed to create
some messaging and then finally there
needed to be some way for them people to
rate their dates once they went on one
so creating a page where people could
rank People based on how respectful they
were timely they were all the works then
boom with those three things I would
have my MVP because of who I am as a
person I can start getting very
distracted with all the other things I
want to add into an app for example with
a dating app something that would be
really cool for me to add is location
services making sure that you feel safe
and whatnot and you can tag your
location so that
everyone God forbid you know nothing
goes wrong everyone knows where you are
so location services every photo and
video that you would want included all
those different things these are just
two examples of how adding features that
would make I believe for a better dating
app just
detracted from the goal of the app
itself which was getting to rap people
number two I don't do the
backend I don't I don't do it I don't do
it I don't do it I'm not a backend
developer so even though I know how to
implement things like authentication
allowing people to log in and sign up
for your app and creating databases that
are good robust and secure and whatnot I
don't want to it takes away time from
doing things that require actual
customization logging in and creating a
database is the same thing every single
time and so why am I spending time doing
something that is pretty standard when I
could work on creating something that
for me doesn't yet exist is a whole new
Innovative idea and is going to be the
thing that sets my my app apart so what
I do instead is I use Google's Firebase
to build out the back end for me this
after doing some research is the
resource that I found to be the best and
easiest to use for me this is not an ad
and I know it sounds like one but I
really do use Firebase all the time and
really really love it by using Firebase
I get to create a login and signup
screen along with databases lots of
databases in a matter of literally
moments and because because it is Google
I don't have to worry about it not being
secure especially if I do end up
releasing the app into the public so
making sure that my back end is handled
by other people I get to focus on the
parts of the app that actually get me
excited using the dating app as an
example again I use Google's Firebase to
allow users to sign up and log in have
the app track their swipes their right
and left swipes and who are matches for
them I also get to implement messaging
within the app which was really cool cuz
I had never had an app with real time
messaging before so that was really
awesome and pretty simple to learn as
well and yeah being able to have a fully
functioning app because the back end is
being handled was really phenomenal so
yes I really recommend it and if anyone
from Google is watching this can you
please sponsor me because I love y'all
and I promise I'll do right by all
number three a little controversial
maybe but like listen to me hear the
words I'm saying okay please I
copy like a lot so so hold up first
let's understand that the things I'm
copying either one my app is not going
to be uh brought to the public and so
it's okay that I'm copying because I'm
doing doing it all for my own learning
and just proving to myself that I can
build this thing so that's number one
why is Okay number two it'll be okay
even if I release it to the public if I
make sure I'm not copying something
proprietary so for example with that
dating app users swipe to get a match
well the swiping feature is something
that is proprietary and trademarked to
Tinder so if I actually wanted to
release this app I could not do that I
could not do that at all swiping to
create a match is trademarked so I would
need to create a whole another mechanism
to allow users to look through their
users say who they like don't like and
then create a match but because I'm not
releasing this app to the public it is
okay for me to have some swiping and
learn through that process you know
copying also comes in handy for me
because I am not good at creating
UI and it's really funny to say that
because I really do like the UI of the
things I have created oh my God what is
that however it takes a lot of research
for me and I guess for actual UI ux
developers that this is what they do too
but it takes a lot of research for me to
get to a UI that I like because I can't
just create it for my own mind I cannot
just think to myself like oh this is how
I want a login screen to look or this is
how I want the homepage to look I cannot
I can my my mind goes blank instead I
need to look for inspiration elsewhere
and then attempt to replicate it when I
was building mostly web apps I would go
to wix.com and look through all their
different templates and see which pages
I liked and which pages I wanted to
recreate onto my own web app now that
I'm building mobile apps primarily I
think about what genre the app that I'm
creating lies in for example dating or
Fitness or social media so now that I
have the genre let me download all of
those different apps in the same genre
and look at how they organize their
things how they put different icons and
displays and whatnot so that is how I
copy to make sure that I am not spending
days on days wondering how I want my app
to look like and there we have it y'all
how I create apps in seven days this is
for web apps mobile apps Etc these TPS
are the same for me and yeah I hope
that's very helpful for y'all please let
me know what y'all are creating if you
know it's not meant for the public
because I don't want your ideas to get
snatched out here but let me know what
you're creating I would love to hear
what's in your portfolio projects and
whatnot and what other videos you'd like
to see from me so no I'll talk to you
later bye